marois bonsoir bondir la marque à 60 est
ce qu'on peut dire que vous êtes
retourné à vos premières amours la
défendre la langue française
tout à fait et avec plaisir d'ailleurs
avec conviction parce que pour moi c'est
ce qui fait la différence dans notre
nation
on peut accueillir le monde en français
on peut participer au mont en français
est actuellement il ya quand même
certains glissement l'effritement c'est
pas majeur c'est pas dramatique mais il
ya un glissement sur la langue de
travail par exemple de moins en moins on
utilise les deux langues de plus en plus
la langue évidemment des commerces on le
sait il ya eu un débat dernièrement
bonjour à une bergerie oui c'est ça
alors moi je crois que là l'un notre
belle un mérite qu'on s'en préoccupe
qu'ont en soient fiers et c'est ce que
je veux pouvoir faire avec la fondation
par l'intermédiaire de la campagne de
financement comme en ile-de-france mans
que vous complaisez avec john parisella
oui enfin ça c'est ça je vous dis non
seulement sommet janis est là et le co
président de la fondation de la langue
française et il est sur mon cabinet de
campagne et ils travailleraient avec moi
à la campagne le message parce que c'est
peut-être un ami de l'émission quand
même il vient toutes les semaines
oui mais oui anglophone francophile
c'est ainsi que se définit
ça c'est pour moi l'un c'est un cadeau
du ciel qui soit 1 mais côtés et aux
côtés de la fondation
pourquoi parce que le message qu'on
envoie c'est que la langue ça nous
rassemble
qu'on soit de différents horizons
politiques de différentes familles
politiques pour nous si on veut
continuer à grandir en français à vivre
en français à travailler en français il
faut qu'on se rassemble justement plus
portent encore un fois d'où nous venons
quelles sont nos convictions
le sondage à bord d'un sondage léger
commandé par la fondation que le journal
de montréal a publié ce matin
il reste que vous avez été longuement
engagé en politique vous l'êtes encore
vous avez connu la période où on
descendait dans la
mieux des manifestations violentes au
tour de personnes jeu des factions
manifestation aujourd'hui à de justes 9%
qui descendraient dans la rue
ma langue française et les gestes que
feraient les gens se seraient des
citoyens se seraient déjà sept
individuel bon 9%
ouais moi aussi ça m'a étonné et je sais
ça veut dire quoi 9 pour ça mais c'est
un bel personnes les enfants
mais effectivement c'est ça fait partie
aussi de se désintéresser on veut à
savoir qu' on pense que des gestes
individuels vont suffire alors qu' il
faut travailler sur tous les fronts oui
une responsabilité gouvernementale ça va
de soi on l'a vu on ne serait pas là
aujourd'hui savait pas eu des
gouvernements par commencer par monsieur
bourassa avec la loi n 2 les dames 1 le
parti québécois camille laurens avec la
loi 101
on serait jamais là où on est
aujourd'hui serait pas eu des gestes
vraiment majeurs important mais en même
temps avec le temps ce sens tant
qu'enfant en confiance et confortable on
pense que tout est gagné et qu'on
apporte à continuer à s' investir alors
oui l'état doit agir
mais les citoyens aussi doivent agir et
c'est dans ce sens là que c'est
important que la société civile se
sentent interpellés et la fondation sait
ce qu'elle veut faire
je veux dire dans un instant sur le type
de projet que vous pourriez valorisée
aux maîtres de l'avant mais vous avez
vous même évoqué les différents
gouvernements alors que vous êtes ses
premières minutes vous avez voulu
modifier la loi et la caq s'y était
opposé si vous aviez le pouvoir demain
matin de faire ce que mieux pour donner
des balises quelles seraient les mesures
que vous favorisez d'abord elle comme je
dis je je pomme internet a posé le
gouvernement à ses responsabilités ça
lui d assumer pour saluer décidé mais
c'est sûr qu'actuellement le milieu du
travail reste un lian fragile
voilà comment je pourrais le dire au
niveau du milieu du travail
nous notre principal badal c'était les
entreprises d'au moins cinquante oui ça
ça jamais pas à ces noms là j'aurais pu
ça peut peut-être de plus quand la loi
101 était adoptée par sa part s'est pas
non plus ses mots c'est pas bien avec ma
ferme mon nom c'est adopter c'était
d'abord la langue de l'école non j'étais
celle là était vraiment au coeur des
premiers débats et des premiers
engagements les premières actions
après ça il ya eu la langue de travail
avec tous les objectifs de francisation
et qui ont donné des fruits encore une
fois qui on voit les résultats mais là
parce qu'il faut reprendre un petit peu
le combat parce que le gouvernement
tienne dans sa réforme de l'immigration
veut mettre l'accent sur la francisation
dit vouloir investir davantage on a
connu au moins je suis assez vieille
quand avoir connu l'époque des coffee
shops de moyens pour intégrer rapidement
les nouveaux arrivants est ce qu'ils
font vraiment partie de la solution
selon vous à moi je suis persuadé de se
persuader d'ailleurs un des grands
projets que porte actuellement la
fondation parce qu'elle existe depuis
quelques années et on a commencé à faire
du financement déjà mais là on va donner
un coup de barre plus sérieux principal
projet c'est un projet qui concerne la
francisation et l'immersion et qui
ressemble plus au coffee qu'on avait il
ya quelques dizaines d'années à savoir
par le jeu par la participation à la
société québécoise soulan de la culture
de la visite de quartier de montréal par
exemple on va réunir des nouveaux
québécois qui vont apprendre à mieux
parler le français à la prendre tout
simplement ou et en même temps à
connaître la culture la réalité de
mentorat la lutte et à aller les
enterrer lors des concerts ouais ça se
fait déjà visité des quartiers montréal
a expliqué bon c'est quoi la petite
histoire du quartier l'impression qu'on
discute on échange
en français il y à des jeux de mots ou
avec des professeurs qui viennent et
bénévolement faire ça derrière da
plusieurs change pas nos mots parce que
s'ils vont elles ont sur une certaine
rue dans le vieux montréal ils vont voir
un niveau restant il s'appelle parlement
les silences sur la rue bernard autres
d'avoir barber shop pendant anglais cela
je pourrais vous dressez de long mais
comment ça se fait que par pourquoi
c'est comme un 10 ans confirme à des
gens d'avoir de permis de bar qui
respectent pas nous et je suis je sais
parce que des fois il ya de la
négligence parfois il ya un désintérêt
ou quoi que ce soit dans le rapport de
l'office de la langue française
on remarque une nette amélioration
malgré ce que vous décrivez que moi
aussi je vois bien sûr et ça me choque à
chaque fois mais il ya une nette
amélioration mais encore par exemple
dans l'ouest de l'île une non conformité
dans l'affichage vivait elle est noté
dans le rapport cette lettre parce qu'au
fond les partis politiques en
l'électoralisme
on sait lire de 84 ans s'est soulevée
dans plusieurs dossiers délicats
le clivage actuelle entre les partis
politiques à québec et c'est bien que
vous prenez aussi ils risqueront
reproche au parti libéral d'avoir
négligé les francophones alors ça peut
peut-être expliquer le fait qu'on n'a
pas voulu être plus strict sur la loi
101 ou d'autres mesures parce que on
voulait postale initiation jeunes
anglophones un moment donné et est ce
qu'il faut de repos autres valeurs
transpartisane oui mais ma chérie je
pense que vous ayez des jeunes volonté
je crois quand même de la part de ce
gouvernement qui est à québec maintenant
de mettre l'accent sur une meilleure
francisation meilleur accueil des
nouveaux québécois
il ya eu déjà motion sur ce fameux
bonjour à et qui a été adoptée si je ne
m'abuse à l'unanimité alors oui parce
que c'est à travers ces partis est le
meilleur exemple étant second fait nous
la fondation avec john parisella d'un
côté et puis maxime la porte de l'otan
qui sont vraiment deux points de vue
très opposés au plein d engagement
politique mais la tentation forte
d'interdire le bonjour à vous avez été
ministre de l'éducation vous l'avez été
marin à ce que je peux dire ça comme ça
d'une grande réforme de l'éducation dans
les années 90 et encore aujourd'hui il
ya des gens qui vont dire oui c'est beau
protéger le français
mais le français enseigné à l'école la
qualité du français que québécois les
salles un peu de bon sens donnant encore
oui je suis alors pas devant cela
faisait 6 mai ils ont fait pour que nous
est revenu à 25 13 ans en arrière
comment c'était terrible on n'était pas
capable de bien s'exprimer en français
de dire deux phrases de suite qu'ils
avaient de la vue un bon anglais me
plaît moins les alors on a franchi des
pas formidable mais il faut maintenant
continuer et revenir et se préoccuper de
la qualité du français
moi je suis peut-être un petit peu moins
dur que vous pas je sais que dans les
écoles quand on a fait la réforme mais
qu'on a beaucoup critiqué mon a augmenté
le temps consacré à l'enseignement du
français
par contre quand je vois la bonne
volonté que manifeste plusieurs
immigrants avec des accents incroyable
puis avec parfois le mauvais mots mais
cette volonté de vouloir parler de
harcèlement mais moi je trouve ça
extraordinaire
donc je pense qu'il faut pas
nécessairement opposé la qualité du
français et la nécessité de le prof de
le protéger de le faire valoir et d'en
faire la promotion
on peut penser vous avez pas renoncer à
votre rêve de souveraineté dont je n'ai
pas renoncer est ce que vous pensez que
la souveraineté du québec aurait été le
meilleur atout pour protéger le français
et c'est évident qu'un pays qui a tous
ses moyens peut protéger le français
beaucoup plus beaucoup mieux beaucoup
plus facilement si on veut que s'il est
toujours en train de faire des
représentations au niveau des tribunaux
supérieurs
on l'a vu le loup assad a été débouté
dans certains de ces partis par les
tribunaux supérieurs mais dans un
contexte où nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui il reste qu à peu près tous
les gouvernements sauf peut-être le
dernier gouvernement qui a été un petit
peu
en fait il était très très timide pour
ne pas dire davantage pour faire la
promotion du français le défendre et
cetera il reste que tous les
gouvernements il ya eu dans sa une
volonté exprimée de continuer à en faire
un enjeu majeur
objectif 5 millions pour faire des
miracles guillon c'est petit dans un
sens c'est énorme quand on faut quand il
faut le ramasser c'est pas un très gros
montants mais chaque petit geste compte
et c'est envoyer un message très
important vous pouvez aider à ce que le
français notre langue commune soit un
objet de fierté et soit parlée par tous
ceux et celles qui habitent le québec
dernière question parce que je passais
trop rapidement sur la question des gens
si les jeunes qui décrochent le plus
j'évoquais greta t'entourent ces hausses
et baisses des critères 30 bank ça vous
prendrai mais il ya une chose peut-être
justement parce qu'on respire on ou de
greta on veut protéger la biodiversité
c'est important de protéger la diversité
des langues à travers le monde et des
des états qui porte qui ont une langue
commune à leur ex ante ça devrait nous
convaincre ça devrait atteindre les
jeunes aussi si on disait aux jeunes
écoutez on va maintenant dire aux
peuples autochtones aux premières
nations
vous devez renoncer à votre langue tout
le monde se lèverait je suis persuadé
chez les jeunes en particulier
alors c'est la même chose pour le
français c'est pas parce qu'on est un
peu plus nombreux en amérique elle parle
et qu'on doit pas continuer à protéger
le défend et en faire la promotion
ce qui est le mandat notamment de la
fondation al en france alors vous avez
le français hacker merci l'amérique
merci